So this is a sample of ruthenium sponge. So
the
ruthenium metal has been precipitated to form
very fine
particles. So here we will just open the box
I am rather ashamed that I made a big mistake
about
the name of ruthenium. I thought it referred
to
somewhere in middle Europe perhaps in Czechoslovakia
whereas ruthenium actually comes from Ruthenia
which
is the Latin translation for the country that
is now called
Russia and, in fact, the element Ruthenium
was first
discovered in Russia in the city of Kazan.
Why would that be a particular cause of shame
for you?
Well, because my father was born in Russia
and
therefore to get something connected to Russia
wrong is
a bit embarrassing.
The ruthenium is a very, very reactive metal
especially
when it is formed in this very fine sponge
type material.
Ruthenium was actually discovered relatively
early in
the middle of the 19th century. There is some
discussion,
whether in fact the Swedish chemist Berzelius
analysed
something that contained ruthenium and missed
it or
not, but I am not quite sure about that. But
the reason
why I am interested in this is because I did
my
doctorate with a supervisor and if you look
at his
supervisor and then that Ö then go back one
supervisor
after another you eventually get to the Swedish
chemist
Berzelius who was my great, great, great,
great, great,
great, great supervisor and you will find
that most of the
chemists now working in the world were related
to just a
few pioneering chemists in the 18th century.
So the ruthenium is very finely divided and
if I tip it you
can see in the bottom of the vial very fine
powders but
again because of the particle size this is
really dark,
very black, very nice sample of ruthenium
very useful
for catalytic chemistry.
It is as a catalyst that ruthenium is particularly
famous.
Ruthenium itself if you look at a lump of
the metal is a
kind of silvery colour. This is a sample of
ruthenium as a
catalyst. Now because it is an expensive metal
the
ruthenium is just distributed as a very thin
layer on
silica. Silica is like sand and you can see
that this finely
divided ruthenium looks black. They are very
finely
divided so it has a large surface area so
the molecules
can come in and react it. And my students
were using
this catalyst to react an organic compound,
that is one
with carbon and hydrogen and to get it to
react with
more hydrogen and so they lent me this catalyst
so I
could show it to you. There are other ruthenium
catalysts which dissolve in the solution that
you are
trying to get the reaction to go. And there
is a very
famous catalyst named after the American chemist
Bob
Grubbs, who won the Nobel prize about 4 years
ago,
and his catalyst does a reaction which most
people even
some chemists had not heard of called which
is called
metathesis in which double bonds between two
carbon
atoms are broken and joined together in a
different way.
And you can use this for all sorts of things
you can make
plastics out of oils; you can make new sorts
of wax; you
can make a really great sort of wax that has
oxygen
atoms in it; and if you use this for candles
then the
oxygen atoms make fragrance molecules dissolve
much
better than in ordinary wax. So you can have
a
Christmas candle which, when you light it,
smells of
Christmas pudding or smells of alcohol or
vanilla or
whatever spice you want. You canít do that
with an
ordinary wax but this ruthenium catalyst opens
up all
sorts of things so that is why he got the
Nobel Prize.
He got the Nobel Prize because he made nice
smelling
candles?
No, he got the Nobel Prize because he invented
the
catalyst that opened up all sorts of reactions
that
otherwise could not be done. Bob Grubbs compound
has
ruthenium and his is the most widely used
and it is now
used in a whole series of industrial processes.
This is
another compound of ruthenium which you can
see is a
rather nice red colour and it has the rather
unromantic
name of ruthenium Bpy three times or chemists
who use
it call it RuBpy. And the point about this
compound is
that it absorbs light well and it is very
stable, you can
shine light on it, very intense light for
a long time and
the compound does not decompose, it does not
change.
But what it can do when you shine light is
that you can
move electrons around inside the compound
and this
compound and ones like it are being used by
people to
try and capture the light from the sun - capture
solar
energy